foreign
s us up next in Vancouver Washington
Jonathan welcome to the show
hi guys thanks for having me absolutely
how can we help today
yeah so I am currently a 19 year old
full-time working full-time college
student
um I actually just recently I just
bought a car in March of this year and I
don't pay a dime for college because I
work through FedEx and FedEx pays for
all my college
I've been working since I was about 16
years old
um and I have had a little bit of a
spending issue uh and I only have about
two thousand dollars in my savings
account so I was wondering if you guys
could give me some ways to budget my
money better and just say you know my
friends asked me to go out and say no
and have that uh that um what's the word
I'm looking for
discipline
yes yes yeah so George is the money guy
let George work on the old budget for
you I'm curious what are you spending
the money on do you think you know like
what are your major areas of expenditure
yeah so I actually refinanced my car I
was paying an arm and a leg a month
about 400 a month just for the car
payment alone and another 270 just for
my insurance
um so I just refinanced the car and a
lot of it was going to my bills I'm very
independent I'm on my own phone plan I
pay for my own gas my own groceries a
lot of things
um I just the stuff that I do save and
I'm I have quite a bit left over at the
end of the month I just spent on impulse
decisions uh like impulse buys
okay so Jonathan what are you making
right now
I make 22.90 an hour and about 40 000 a
year wow while being in school full time
yes when do you graduate
all right I'm planning on graduate 2026.
okay so you just started yes sir and
what career field are you looking to get
into
law enforcement okay so you have two
grand you've been working for three
years now you're a young guy and you
said you paid cash for this car so you
don't have the car payment anymore
no I actually do have the car payment
explain that you said you paid cash for
the car
oh no I did not pay cash I put a three
thousand dollars down okay that's very
different what's the car worth
uh it's worth about 20 000 right now
okay and what is left on the loan
uh about twenty three thousand yes okay
I mean it's a lot of car for your income
we we say we don't want all the things
with the motors in it to add up to more
than half of your annual income and you
will right there
yeah uh for a 19 year old to be driving
a car that nice uh so let's just say you
keep the car what is the plan to pay
this thing off
uh just keep on my payments um I like I
said I refinanced this my payment did go
down but I'm planning on that's not
solving the problem you just move the
money around
yeah so I was planning on just paying
more uh than my monthly plan payment was
just to add up um some extra or take off
some time to pay it off okay do you have
any other debt
uh no sir okay are you driving for FedEx
or are you uh in an office or a
warehouse I would work at the airport so
no I'm not driving okay
George I would I would like to see him
you know he doesn't have a lot of time
but I'd like to see I I'd like to see
him change his budget so radically that
he can get not upside down so get on the
right side of this thing and then sell
the car and go with a three or four
thousand dollar car yeah is that too
extreme well we say if you can't pay off
the car within two years then we got to
sell the car right it's just too much of
your world wrapped up in this thing and
your future is too important for you to
just have these payments you're sending
out on top of the spending habits and
all of a sudden man you're making great
money you got nothing to show for it and
part of that is the debt part of it's
the spending we can get both under
control uh one of those ways is through
a budget which it doesn't sound like
you're doing right now when we want to
help with that I'm going to gift you one
year of every dollar premium if you're
willing to use it are you willing to get
on a plan yes sir okay so when you open
up every dollar you're going to list
your income at the top followed by all
of your expenses and here's the thing
you are the boss of that budget and when
it's done it's the boss of you
yeah and so what that means is once you
set it you go man I am not spending more
than 200 on food this month on I'm not
spending more than 70 on entertainment
this month that means when your friends
ask you out say hey dude come out with
us you go sorry dude it's not in the
budget and they're gonna say dude you're
so lame man you get a lot and you're
gonna say that's cool uh you guys can
come to my place we can get some pizzas
and just hang out
and if they say no to that it may be
time to find better friends if they're
just unwilling to to compromise and
cheer you on with your financial journey
and uh with every dollar I'm going to
gift you FPU I think going through that
will motivate you because you need a
long-term why right now you're a young
guy you're driven already the fact that
you're at this place in life but if you
have a long-term mindset I want 29 year
old Jonathan to be proud of the
decisions that 19 year old Jonathan made
yeah that's a different mindset to have
because most people your age are
thinking about next weekend not 10 years
from now
yeah by the way Jonathan that's
incredible advice and that's what you're
going to have to have at the top of your
mind and you need a true visual of what
George is talking about where do you
want to be at 29 get a clear I mean
crystal clear image of that and when
your buddies start giving you a hard
time come on man let's go man let's go
to the club blah blah blah whatever it
is they say these days so the kids go to
the club I don't know I'm I'm so old I
don't even know but I'm not even sure
where the voice came from but the point
is is the ability to say no
only comes from
a decision that is made much earlier
and you make that decision and then you
manage that decision every time you're
tempted you make the big decisions early
in life
and then you manage those decisions the
rest of your life a lot of wisdom in
that case